Good afternoon, everyone.
I'm very excited to announce
our last and final keynote,
Jeff Leek. We are
particularly lucky to get
Jeff Leek as a keynote
speaker right now because he's
in the middle of a
cross-country move
to start a new position as
VP and Chief data officer
at the Fred Hutchinson
Institute for Cancer Research.
So Jeff is famous for very many
things, but two in particular
that I wanted to talk about.
The first is along with
Roger Peng and Brian Caffo,
Jeff taught really, like,
the first data science
MOOC which introduced R
to literally millions of people,
which is pretty amazing.
The other thing
I love about Jeff
is that him and I
disagree on a few things.
And one of the
things in particular,
several years ago he wrote a
blog post why I don't use ggplot2,
but what I love
about Jeff's writing
is he articulates his position
so clearly,
like, even as I was
reading the article,
I was like nodding along,
yeah, yeah, that makes sense.
So please join me in
welcoming Jeff Leek.
Thanks very much.
And thanks, Hadley.
I know you've been saving
that up for a minute.
I will say that I have become
a ggplot2 convert since then.
So yes, Yes.
I'm not even playing
to the audience there.
Yeah so I'm very
excited to be here today
to talk to you about DataTrail,
which is an effort that we've
been running in Baltimore for
the last four or five years
to build inclusive, community
based data science education.
And I hope that you'll
be excited to go back
into your communities and also
build programs and connect
to your communities.
One thing I wanted
to start off with,
though, is I wanted to just say
I'm so excited to be in a room
with all of you.
I've seen tons of
people that I haven't
seen for 2 and 1/2 years.
The very last conference
I went to in January 2020,
before this one was
RStudio conf in San Francisco.
I then got on an airplane,
flew back to Baltimore
and the world ended.
I know that all of us over
the last 2 and 1/2 years
have gone through
many, many things,
they're both individual
and collective.
And I just want
to express the joy
that I feel to be back
together with people
and back with the R
community, and especially
this amazing community that
the band formerly called
RStudio has put together.
And so I'm really
excited about that.
And I just wanted to
express my gratitude
both for the invitation
to speak here today.
And to the community that's
been built, all of you,
to coming out and sticking
around for the last talk.
Before I go any further,
I also wanted to make sure
I Thank the people that did
all the real important work.
This is the DataTrail
core team, Ashley Johnson,
Simone Sawyer, Ed Sabatino,
Davon Person. And Ashley
and Davon are
actually here today.
And if they could stand up
and wave there somewhere
in the audience, there
they are right there.
Anything good you hear,
anything good hear is
definitely because of them.
Anything silly or
misguided is due to me.
This is a kind of project
that can't be done
by just a couple of people.
There's been a huge
community of people
that have helped
us over the years
develop the DataTrail program.
And I wanted to say that we're
so grateful to all the people
that helped out.
One of the things I wanted
to talk a little bit about
is my own journey to
where I am here today.
As Hadley mentioned, I'm
in the middle of a move
to take a big, exciting new
job right near my family,
which I'm really excited about.
But I didn't start
there, as none of us did.
I started off as just a nerdy
kid from a very small town
in Idaho.
This is an embarrassing picture
that usually other people
show in a presentation,
but how did that happen?
How did I go from nerdy kid
in Idaho to where I am today?
And I imagine we all had a
similar kind of journey, right?
We had to know that this was
a field which some are just
discovering now.
Some discovered a
long time ago, we
had to have access to the
equipment and the training
and the connections to be able
to be in a room here today.
But more importantly than that,
we had I had to have help.
This is not something
that I did on my own.
I had to be lifted
up at various points
of my career from my
undergrad advisor, Jim Powell,
to my grad advisor John Storey,
to Giovanni Parmigiani, who
recruited me to
Baltimore by saying,
do you want to live
near your wife?
To Rafa Irizarry, who
was my main faculty
mentor in my early
years, and many,
many other people who have
worked with me just like me.
I'm sure you feel the same way
that there are people that have
helped you out in your life.
And so I wanted to
just take a minute
because we're all here together
to turn to your neighbor
and maybe tell
them about somebody
that helped you along your way.
We're going to just
take a minute here,
and I'd like you to
tell somebody about one
of your mentors, somebody
who helped you out when
you had a moment of need.
So I'm just going to
give a brief pause
and make it a
little interactive.
Please talk to your neighbor.
If you're online on discord,
you can talk the same way.
This is awesome.
All right.
I know that this conversation
could last a long time.
And I hope you'll continue
that conversation later.
And I hope it reminded you
of somebody that helped you
along the way, because the
DataTrail program we're building
is about helping other people.
And so one of the key
things that we realize
that I think
everybody recognizes
is that talent is
equally distributed.
So these are some young
people from our second cohort
of DataTrail scholars
in East Baltimore.
These are folks that
grew up around there
and are incredibly
talented young people.
And there's an important
thing that even
though the talent is
equally distributed,
opportunity isn't always.
So this is data from the
economic opportunity atlas,
and it says that if you
were born and grew up
in this neighborhood, the median
family income when you get
to age 34 is $18,000 a year.
So that whole neighborhood,
even though it's
right next to a multibillion
dollar medical institution,
doesn't have access
to the same career
opportunities that say I did
when I grew up out in Idaho.
And it's not just Baltimore
where this is true.
If you look at the
economic opportunity atlas,
where I'm going in Seattle,
Pittsburgh, Chicago, Tampa Bay,
New York city, no
matter where you look,
there are these
opportunity deserts.
And so how do we
create opportunity
in these opportunity deserts?
How do we actively go out
and promote opportunities
for folks that grew up there?
And it's not just economic.
It's not just an
economic calculation.
It's also a health calculation.
I was in a school
of Public Health.
I'm moving to a Cancer Center.
I care a lot about health.
This is a plot.
It doesn't look like real
data, but it is real data.
This is a plot of income
percentile on the x-axis.
And on the y-axis
is life expectancy.
You've got one line for
female, one line for male.
And you can see that there's
near-perfect correlation
between how much money
your parents made
and your life expectancy on
average in the population,
which is kind of incredible.
Education is still
the best treatment
we have to cure the problem
of lack of opportunity.
This is a plot that shows
how much your parents made
on the x-axis.
And on the y-axis
is how much you
make after going to
different types of schools.
Each color represents a
different type of school
and the lines are
relatively flat,
which means if you get
into one of those schools,
you have a very good chance
of moving up economically.
But the challenge is
you can't always get in.
So this is a similar plot.
This is college's,
each dot is a college.
On the x-axis is how likely you
are to get into that college
on a scale from 0 to 100.
If you're a parent, based
on your parent's income
and on the y-axis
is how likely you
are to be in the top
quartile of income
after completing college there.
So places like Johns Hopkins,
where I used to be at,
have very low access.
If your parents didn't
have a lot of money,
it's unlikely you're going
to get into that college.
But if you go
there, you're going
to have a very good chance of
having a high economic return.
And so you can
actually calculate
this for every college.
You can say, multiply the
probability you get in.
If you're from the
lowest quintile
of income times the probability
you'll be in the highest income
if you get it once you get out.
And that can be what
we call mobility rate.
This is a calculation
developed by some economists.
And so the best generators of
mobility in the United States
are typically large public
institutions, community
colleges, technical
colleges that
produce the highest level
of economic mobility
in our country.
And they're driven by access.
So you can see that the
success rates don't have
to be in the high 90s to be.
These are the very
top colleges in the US
and it's driven by how
accessible that education is.
And so we're all here
because we love data science.
We love R, we love Python, we
love all the other languages.
And it's a high growth
and wage job category.
And so how do we get more
people to have access to this?
As Hadley mentioned,
we've been teaching
massive online open
courses about data science
for a long time, and they've now
enrolled more than 10 million
people across the world.
And these programs can
lead to big income gains.
So here I'm showing
a plot on the x-axis
is the cost of the program.
And I've got graduate school,
undergraduate, associate's
degree, and on the
y-axis is the increase
in income post program.
And for one of our
data science sequences,
you get nearly the same
amount of income boost
as you would for a college
or advanced degree,
even for a much lower cost.
So that seems pretty exciting.
And originally we
were thinking, OK,
this is how we generate
this mobility at scale.
But as, not just us,
but many, many people
have noted Coursera
classes, bootcamps,
those sorts of things.
They tend to benefit the
already well educated.
Most of the people taking these
programs are actually already
have bachelor's degrees,
master's degrees,
professional degrees in
a career transitioning.
So we're not really generating
access for the people
the mobility rate applies to.
And so what we try
to do is, can we
create opportunities
for the folks that
aren't taking the
massive online open
courses who haven't
been introduced to R
via these scalable programs?
And lest I say that we're
the only people thinking
about this, there
are a ton of amazing.
I've been to talks
today from Openscapes
to you met amazing people from
various parts of the world.
We've got R-Ladies,
we've got Data Carpentry,
the Bioconductor team, so
many people that are also
trying to do this to
try to lift people up
through the power of data
science education and data
science opportunities.
But the reality is there are
significant barriers to entry.
I showed this graph a
minute ago for myself,
but it applies to anyone who
wants to get into data science.
You have to know
about data science.
You have to have the income
security to participate.
You have to have access to a
computer, programs, instruction,
connections, the right jobs.
It's a lot.
So how do we take these
barriers down one by one?
So first you have to
know about data science.
And so the way that
we've addressed
that problem with
our program is we
actually go out into the
community and we partner
with community based education
associations like historic East
Baltimore Community Action
Coalition and the HeartSmiles,
who train young people to get
their high school diplomas,
who train them to get
technical training.
And we teach them
about the opportunities
that are there in data science.
We partner with them to recruit
students for our program.
Then how do we
address the computer?
So this is the thing that maybe
kicked off all of this for me.
I love Chromebooks and you
can get a Chromebook for $450.
We've seen the power
of this with education
over the last couple of
years with the pandemic.
And it turns out that
you can be a data
scientist on a Chromebook.
And this is where,
again RStudio and Posit
have been a major
player in what we've
been able to do by
creating RStudio Cloud.
We were one of
the first programs
to jump on to that platform.
So that you can do
all of your data
science work directly
on the cloud.
It's such an
incredible tool and I'm
so grateful that
we've been able to use
that to help train people.
And so you can be a data
scientist on a chromebook,
you can use Google
Slides and Google Sheets
and you can use RStudio and you
can teach people how to do it.
And they don't need a MacBook
Pro to be a data scientist.
There's also barriers to entry.
You know, if you need
to buy a MacBook pro,
it costs you $3,000.
If you only if your family
only made $18,000 last year,
you can't participate
in a program like this.
So with funding
from Johns Hopkins
originally, later from
the Abell Foundation,
we actually pay the students
to complete the courses.
So as they finish our
massive online open courses,
they earn money so that they can
participate in it like a part
time job.
Thank you.
Yeah Thanks to Abell.
Thanks to Johns Hopkins.
We also need access
to the right kind
of instruction and the
appropriate programs.
So, here's where
R really shines.
Why would we use R?
I get asked this
question all the time
when we built our entire
training program around R.
I know that there's
also Python people here
and we love Python too, but
we built our whole program
around R and I get asked
a lot why we did that.
And the reason why is we wanted
to minimize the time to magic.
So with just a few lines
of code, R Markdown,
with just a few lines of
code can put a website up
on the web that's interactive
that you can show off
to your friends
and to your family.
With things like the bigrquery
package and dbplyr
you can connect to
massive databases
and analyze huge
collections of data
with just a few lines of code.
And with things like
Shiny, flexdashboard,
Shiny dashboards,
those, you can also
write just a few
lines of code. Here
it's like 34 lines
of code that creates
an interactive
NHANES website.
So with minimizing
time to magic,
we can train people very
quickly to do incredible things.
And then we can build
a program around it.
We can build a
community around it
that helps support
people as they go through
and they learn how
to do data science.
We do this on Basecamp.
You can also do it on Slack or
any other community building
platform, but there
has to be both
an online and
in-person component.
So then the last
part is you have
to think about, OK, say we
have a training program.
So we've trained them to do it.
We've built it in R. Then they
need access to connections.
They need to be able
to actually get a job.
And so here we can
again, leverage the
R community, the people
here in the audience today
to help make connections
between the young people
that we're training and
the broader community
and opportunities
that are out there.
And this ecosystem really works.
We've had 80% success rate
in our Johns Hopkins pilot
that I'm going to
tell you a little bit
about completing the training.
Just to give you some idea,
massive online open
courses in general -
the completion rate hovers
somewhere between 2% and 5%.
So 80% completion rate for this
massive online open sequence
is an incredible testament
to the will and intelligence
of the people that we're
training in the community.
After they, after they
finished the training program,
though, we want to put them
into opportunities that
can help change their lives.
And so their reality is there
are significant barriers
to entry to these jobs.
But we've partnered
with programs
that support internships that
represent a soft landing place.
We teach people data
science in 16 weeks.
That is not a lot of time
to learn data science
and learn how to be
a data scientist.
So we partner with programs
like Urban Alliance,
and we have a couple
of people here,
Chaz and LaShonda
from Urban Alliance.
I don't know where
they're sitting,
but they're also in the
audience here today, over there.
And they're helping us build
internship programs that
support the long component
of training that's
developing the soft skills,
developing the approach
to work that will let them be
in these careers long term.
So I'll tell you a little
bit now about our pilot
that we ran in Baltimore.
This is what the whole
pilot has felt like.
We started this off with just an
idea and absolutely no program.
And so at every turn, it
felt like we're barely
getting the train
tracks together
in time to be able to
continue to run the program.
So this is how it started.
In February 2018, we started
developing content for our data
science training program.
We met with HEBCAC, Historic
East Baltimore Community Action
Coalition, in April of
2018, and we told them
we were developing a program and
we were excited about working
with them.
They got very excited and they
said, can we start tomorrow?
Remember, we had started
developing our program
in February.
It was April.
And so they said, OK, we'll
give you a little time.
We'll start in May.
We had to develop this much
content between February
and May.
So we're talking 12
courses to cover everything
from how to use computers to
how do you organize projects
to the tidyverse to
written an oral communication
to how to get a job. 12
courses in five months.
So this was me.
I was a little stressed.
I was worried that we
wouldn't be able to do it.
But fortunately we had some
really incredible help.
So at the time, there are
two people I particularly
want to call out Shannon
Ellis and Aboozar Hadavand,
who are postdocs in my group.
One was an economist
working on studying
how the outcomes of these
massive online open courses.
And one was a geneticist.
But they pitched
in and they said,
we can build this whole
program in that much time.
So they assembled this
collaborative team
and on github,
using R Markdown,
we built this entire
program in that much time.
We did have some
challenges along the way,
though. As we were
building the program,
the courses like getting
and cleaning data
were being updated because
new packages would come out.
So this is a plot.
On the x-axis is time.
Thousands of R scripts after
the start of a program
and on the y-axis is the
usage of different packages.
There's one that
kind of stands out,
and that's because right in the
middle of when we're developing
these courses, dplyr comes out
rendering half of our program
totally valueless, and we
have to start from scratch.
Thanks, Hadley.
So what we had to do is
regenerate all of our materials
and we now pay very
careful attention
to what the RStudio
and Posit folks
are doing on their GitHub repos
as we're developing courses.
We built this program.
And so now we were ready
to start training people.
So we thought, well,
let's start May 1st.
How long does the program last?
They asked me.
We'd never run it before.
In fact, we had just
built the program.
I don't know how long
the program lasts.
Let's call it 12 weeks.
So I told them we were
going to do it in 12 weeks.
Shannon, Aboozar, and I
said, OK, we're going
to finish it by August 31.
Despite us still having
to fix up courses,
all the bugs, our
two pilot candidates
finished in about 14 weeks.
16 weeks, sorry.
So that was
pretty incredible.
We took two young
people from HEBCAC.
They'd never heard of
data science before.
We got them through an
entire 12 course MOOC
sequence they both finished.
It was awesome.
Now they'd finish the data
science training program,
and we realized we
got to get them a job.
And so there's a
bit of a challenge
that we ran into that you
may have run into sometimes
in your search for jobs.
This is the roles
and responsibilities
you may experience that you need
to do once you get on the job.
And this might be the job
experience they're asking for.
We saw that a lot.
We saw that there
were jobs that we
knew that our
graduates could perform,
but were not necessarily
advertised in the right way.
Moreover, we ran into the
Fair Labor and Standards Act,
and I learned more about
the legal requirements
around employment than
I would care to repeat.
But the basic idea is
that because they're not
computer scientists,
they actually write text
and they write prose
and things like that.
They don't qualify to be
exempt employees unless they
have a bachelor's degree.
So we need them to be
hourly data scientist jobs,
which it turns out a few
companies have, but many don't.
So with this close, we
train these young people,
they're brilliant.
They finish the program,
but we can't quite
get them in to the finish line.
So what are we going
to do about this?
How are we going to actually
get them to the point
where they can be
employed and they
can move to a different
place in their life?
So I did what anyone would do.
I called a friend of mine,
an old family friend who
was a consultant for IBM, and I
said, let's start a consulting
company.
And so he and I started
a consulting company,
and we would do data science
consulting work for companies
all around the country.
We would do them for
Fortune 500 companies,
for small companies,
small mom and pop shops.
And all of the data science
work that was being done
was being done by
graduates of our program
that we were hiring from
the training program.
This worked great.
The graduates did
an amazing job.
We were able to
do it, but we were
a bootstrapped, bespoke data
science consulting company.
And ultimately,
that's not the way
that this is going to
work going forward.
So the next part
of our story is we
brought on Ashley
Johnson, who's here
today as a core
member of our team
and is the program
manager for DataTrail.
And she managed through a lot
of hard work, blood, sweat,
and tears to get our HR
systems at Johns Hopkins, which
is a massive organization that
where HR does not move quickly
to create a new job code.
So that we could hire
people at Johns Hopkins,
specifically with the
credentials from our program.
There's an incredible
testament to Ashley's patience
and brilliance getting
this through the system.
And it allowed us to
hire Davon Person, who's
a graduate of our program,
to be the main TA for all
of our future training cohorts.
This kind of work has
to be done by advocates
within an organization.
This isn't data science work.
This is the hard
blocking and tackling
that needs to be done by
each and every one of us
if we want to build new
opportunities where there
weren't opportunities before.
Build new bridges.
We have this phrase
that we always
say when we're building
this program hard things are
hard to do when you want
to make a big change
in the way the world works.
It's not going to be easy.
It's going to be
hard, and that means
it's going to be hard to do.
But it's worth doing,
even though it is hard.
So I think I'm going to
take another brief pause
and I'm going to have all of
you think about sometime you
accomplish something,
something that was really hard
and that you're really
proud that you did,
even though it
took a lot of work
and it was kind of painful.
Tell your neighbor about it.
We'll give you another
couple of minutes
and then we'll come back.
All right.
We'll jump back into it.
I'm stoked about this.
Everybody was very
excited to tell each other
about their accomplishments.
That's great.
I'm excited about it.
Hopefully I'll get to hear some
of them later from some of you.
So again, hard things are
hard, but they're worth doing,
as you all just were telling
each other about something
that you were really proud of.
But it took a lot of work to do.
So it's exciting to be
a part of those things.
It's exciting to be
and compelling to be
part of something that feels
like it's really important,
even if it takes a lot of work.
I'm going to tell you a
little bit about the impact
of this program
and what it's meant
to the people in the
community and to us.
So first I wanted to mention
Davon, who's here today.
Again, he's I can't
remember where he is,
but Davon is our lead.
There he is.
All right.
Davon is our curriculum
lead for DataTrail.
He's a graduate of the
program, an incredible guy.
I knew Davon was going to be
the right guy for our program
when we had a dinner at
our house for all the
DataTrail trainees.
He came to my house and
he spent the whole dinner
teaching my, at the
time, eight-year-old son
had to play chess.
Unfortunately, that's
bad for me because now I
get beat all the time at chess.
But it was a great testament
to the incredible talent
that he has for helping
people learn how to do things.
So it's so great to have
him as part of the program.
Another incredible
part of this program
is that one of our graduates,
while working at Problem
Forward, worked on an
HBO documentary called
The Slow Hustle.
If any of you have seen it.
If not, you should
definitely go out and see it.
They did a bunch of analysis
of the historic redlining
in Baltimore's community
that prevented people
from buying houses in different
communities within Baltimore.
It's quite a famous
problem around the world,
but in Baltimore, it's
particularly transparent
how a problem it was, and so was
credited actually in the movie
credits for their
analysis of the data that
showed this redlining.
It really unbelievable
effort that was
made by a DataTrail graduate.
Thank you, yeah.
And so this is
an example of a quote.
We collect quotes
from all the people
that come from the program.
So it says, "It gave
me a new direction
and taught me you
can be different,
go a different route
than your parents.
Not always hanging on to
what society tells you,
you can follow
your own protocol,
so it just gave me a sense
like a new world or a new field
and a new life
that I got to see."
It's such an incredible
thing to be a mentor.
It's such an
incredible thing to be
a person that makes a
connection to a new field,
to a new opportunity.
And it's been incredibly
rewarding to see
that happen, not just
for us, but watch
it scale as Davon makes
connections for people,
as Candice makes
connections for people.
As Ashley makes
But we did learn some
lessons along the way.
I mentioned that we were a
train that was constantly trying
to take things off the track.
This was almost
all due to the fact
that I'm a biostatistician
by training.
I don't know the first thing
about building a community
organization and had
to learn over and over
and over again, things that
people who work in the field
have known for a long time.
We learned those by listening,
by paying attention,
by spending time in
those communities.
But they're important
and hard lessons.
One of the most important
things we learned
is that I'm here
at a data science
conference an R conference.
But data science is actually
the easy part of all of this.
The young people that go
through our program are bright.
They're good at computers.
Pretty soon, they're teaching
us about data science.
That's not the hard part.
The hard part is
everything around it.
All the stuff that comes up
in somebody's life, you know,
housing falling
through, not being
able to get transportation,
not having the access
to the resources,
not having access
to the connections of
people that can hook you up
with a job or an opportunity.
Those are the things that really
take work to make something
like this happen.
The other thing that we
learned is that building trust.
It takes time.
You know, we're
working in a community.
We're working you know, we come
from Johns Hopkins at the time
now from the Hutch,
you know, and we're
making these connections to
community based organizations
who've been working in those
communities for a long time.
But we're new.
You know, we're not we're not
part of that community yet.
And it takes time
and it takes effort
and it takes being there
all the time consistently
to be able to build that trust
so that you can actually build
a relationship that will
last and will create people
that move on to the next step.
You know, it's hard to
tell somebody you just
met what's really going on.
One of the things that's
always the biggest
challenge in our program
is getting people
to ask questions.
It's intimidating to
ask questions when
you're starting something new.
It's a scary thing to admit
you don't know something.
And so it's an important
part of the program
to build trust, to build those
connections so that people can
comfortably ask you what's
wrong, tell you
what's wrong, ask you for help.
It's one of the
things I appreciate,
to an incredible degree
about the community here
is that we're open to questions
that when people email
you or tweet at you or
send you a GitHub request,
you answer those questions
politely and kindly
and with compassion.
It means the world to people
who are just starting out.
And we also need
to be able to scale
employment and internships.
Our original idea was
basically born out of panic.
I hadn't really
thought through how
we were going to get people
jobs at the end of this training
program we started.
That's my fault.
We needed something
a little better than just
starting a random consulting
company.
And so we need to be able
to scale those employment
opportunities and those
internship opportunities.
And this is where partnerships
with organizations that know
what they're doing is critical.
So we've been working with
the Urban Alliance, who
has a whole program and a whole
system for managing internships
for young people who come from
communities like the one we're
trying to serve.
And so we're
partnering with them
to be able to run these
internships in a long term
and sustainable way.
We also need advocates.
So one of the things
that we've realized
is we're going through
this program is the thing
that Problem Forward did.
It wasn't that it was a data
science consulting company.
It wasn't that it was related
to the training program.
It was that we could advocate
on behalf of young people
who come out of these
communities, who are talented
individuals, who have
credentials that maybe look
a little different, who
maybe don't have all
of the background that other
people might have when they're
first starting out, but
that are really talented
and could be spectacular
if just given a chance.
And so within all organizations,
we need those advocates,
and those advocates have
to be people like you,
people like me, people who
have opportunity already
and can reach out and try
to support somebody else
as they go through
that same journey
that we all went through that
I had to go through when I came
from Idaho to get to here.
And the other thing we need is
mutually intensive learning.
It's been an
incredible experience,
I think, for both
sides, both people
that are coming
out of the training
program and the mentors and
teachers and hiring partners
to learn about each
other, to learn
about the things we do well.
You know, I don't know the
first thing about Instagram
and TikTok and all that kind
of stuff, but I'm learning.
I'm learning.
And that's how we're getting
into new communities.
And I'm learning that
from the people that
are in the training program.
So I think that
there's a way that we
can learn from each other.
It's not just teaching data
science in one direction,
it's also learning in the
other direction as well.
And that mutually
intensive learning
can really develop
a relationship
that lasts a long time.
So what's the future?
What's the future of DataTrail?
I told you about the pilot.
I told you about where we were.
We're in a great place
with DataTrail now,
and we're just starting
to think about the future
and how do we scale this up?
So our DataTrail model has
three big components now.
There's colleges and
universities or training
partners in general.
They provide tutors and
educational support.
Then there's hiring
partners or mentors.
They provide the mentors and
opportunities for the people
once they finish the
training program.
And then we have
nonprofit and community
based partners who
do the hard work
of supporting the whole person.
Because when you're
doing a training program
and you're coming from a
community that doesn't have
a lot of resources, small
things can cause big problems
if you don't have
the support you
need to get through
the training program.
And so the three
groups working together
can really provide that
infrastructure, that underlying
infrastructure that gives
somebody the opportunity
to come from a community
without a lot of opportunity
into a place where they can
be a leader in the field.
So in Baltimore, we do this with
the Johns Hopkins data science
lab, providing the
tutoring and support.
So we've got Candice
Savonen in here
who's from the, was at the
Johns Hopkins data science,
and that lab is now at the
Fred Hutch data science lab.
I don't know where she is,
but she could stand up.
But she's helping to
provide the tutoring
and support with Davon.
We have mentors
and opportunities
that we're building out
with Urban Alliance,
and then we have incredible
nonprofit and community
based partnerships
built in Baltimore
that provide social and life
support to the young people who
are going through our programs
so that if something comes up,
they can get that support.
They need to stay in
the program to stick
with it, to get the opportunity
that they're going after.
So this is how our
program works now.
From January to June, we're
recruiting young people.
We're getting into schools,
we're providing content online.
We're trying to get people
excited about data science.
And then from June
to September, we're
doing our training program.
We're actually running
the DataTrail courses
they're going through.
They're getting paid as
they complete the courses
and they're finishing
the program.
And we're also
recruiting mentors.
We're recruiting the
people that are ultimately
going to hire and mentor
and manage the young people
in their first opportunity.
Then from September to
June, they do an internship.
This is supported
by Urban Alliance
and this is a 10 hour a week
internship where they get paid,
it's virtual and they get
mentorship a couple of hours
a week from a mentor at a
hiring company or a partner.
This is how the
program works now.
And so there's an
opportunity for you
to get involved with us at
DataTrail, if you're interested.
There's two different ways.
One is the more heavy duty way,
which is start your own
DataTrail in your own community.
And the other way is to hire
or mentor DataTrail graduates
from our program.
So I'm going to start with
starting your own DataTrail
program.
We talked a little bit
about doing hard things
and we did a hard thing
to set this thing up,
and we've paved a lot
of the ground for you.
So if you're interested in
starting your own DataTrail
community, you can reach out
to Ashley Johnson, to myself,
and we can provide you with
a lot of the background
and materials you need to build
this program in your community.
We can provide start up
documents, relationship
agreements.
We can give you information
on how to get funded.
We provide free courses so
you can access them and train
people in data science.
And then we provide access
to the DataTrail community.
So you can talk
to the people who
are building it in Baltimore
and around the country.
I'm very excited
because the first DataTrail
franchise has started already.
So Madhu and
Melanie contacted us.
They're at Mount Sinai Health
System in New York city,
and they were really
excited about DataTrail.
And the two of them set
up a DataTrail franchise
that's running completely
independently in New York
and is now on its second
cohort of graduates,
placing people in the
medical health system,
placing them at jobs
around New York City.
It's amazing to see how just
a couple of committed people
can have such an
incredible impact
on the lives of young
people in their community.
And I'm so impressed
with the work
that Madhu and Melanie are doing.
Yeah, it's awesome.
So the other way you can get
involved is to hire or mentor.
So we're working
with Urban Alliance,
as I mentioned, and there's
two ways that you can do this.
You could hire DataTrail
graduates into your company
if you have internships
that you want to support.
It's part time internships.
They're remote, paid
internships, and they
can be supported by Urban
Alliance and DataTrail.
In other words, we support
them on the technical side
and Urban Alliance supports
them on the soft skills side.
I'm incredibly
excited to announce
that Posit has committed to
host two of these interns
this fall from our
DataTrail cohort, which
is an amazing opportunity.
And thank you so much.
The other cool
opportunity and this
I'm also wildly excited about, is
that you can mentor DataTrail
graduates as an open
source developer,
so we could place people
directly into companies.
But there's also an incredible
opportunity for our DataTrail
grads to make an impact on the
open source and open science
community.
And so the idea here is we get
philanthropic and corporate
funding to pay for
the internship,
and then we will recruit mentors
from the open source community
to work on their projects.
And so Posit again has
committed incredibly
to fund one of these this fall.
If you're an open
source developer that's
looking for somebody to work
with you on your project
and you're looking for
a talented young person,
you should come and talk
to us after the event.
And then the Abell
Foundation is also
agreed to fund one more this
fall from our training program
and that represents
our entire training
cohort is going to
get funded this year
and we're excited about
building this over time.
So if you have an
idea about a program
that if you want to either
mentor a student this fall
or you want to start thinking
about next fall, get in touch.
I've got the email addresses
up here of Chas Ackley,
who's the Urban Alliance
partner, the director
of the Baltimore office,
and Ashley Johnson, who's
the director of the
DataTrail program in Baltimore.
And you can reach out to
either of them or to me
if you're excited about
mentoring a DataTrail grad.
I'd like to finish, though,
talking about not just Data
Trail, because this
is a cool opportunity
and we would love to
work with all of you,
but you can also do it in any
other way that you feel like.
I think just bringing
it back to what I said
at the beginning of the talk.
This is an incredible
opportunity
to be together, to build
community together.
And I think that what
Posit and RStudio have done
is just an amazing way
to make us all feel
part of the same community.
One of the things that we
should do is help each other,
whether that's
through DataTrail
or through Openscapes
or R-Ladies or Data
Carpentry or any other program
that you're excited about.
And there's this
quote that I love.
I emailed my undergrad
advisor when I first
got my very first faculty
job, and I told him
I was so excited about it.
I got to live near my wife,
I got to live in Baltimore,
I got to do my dream job.
And he wrote me back that
he was really glad to hear.
And he said, mentorship is
a debt you can't pay off.
I had some mentors who
helped me when I was young
and I can never
pay it off to them.
I can only pay it
forward to other people.
And so he said, Thank you for
helping me pay off my debt.
And I feel like we're
all in this room.
Owe a debt of gratitude to
all of the people that have
helped us be here to get today.
And whichever way you
choose to express that,
I hope you'll think about
ways that you can pay off
your or pay forward your debt.
There's almost nothing
more rewarding than this.
It's been an incredible journey.
And I think that the people
here today, the DataTrail
folks, the Urban Alliance folks,
the Heartsmiles folks, the HEBCAC
folks, they're all
here to say that this
is one of the most
rewarding things you can do
is create opportunities
for young people.
With that,
I'll Thank you.
And at the conclusion of the
talk, after this is all over,
I'm going to be hanging out
up here in front with Ashley,
with Chas, with
Davon, with Candice.
If you're excited about
mentoring or talking
about DataTrail, please
come and hang out and talk.
And we'd love to
get to talk to you.
Thank you very much
for your attention.
Thanks, Jeff.
Now we engage in light
banter for, live banter,
for one to 2 minutes until
people ask questions and have
a chance to upvote them.
So light banter about ggplot2?
Yeah, sure.
I'm glad I got my digs
in before the talk.
Yeah, that was,
that was a good investment.
I feel like that's
the only reason
I got the invitation
was so Hadley
got to say that. I was actually
reading through there's
been a few.
You also wrote one
on tidy data that
wasn't really like against
tidy data, but I was like,
no, that was very much like
these are some use cases
or it's like not great
for and yeah, it was.
Right Yeah.
Oh, man.
I'm getting all the gripes.
Somebody save me with
the question, please.
OK we do have one
question, one question,
one just one to save you.
Are the mentoring opportunities
only available in Baltimore?
No, these are remote online
mentorship opportunities.
So if you are an
open source developer
and are excited about
mentoring a young person,
it's going to get paid for
by the Abell foundation.
It's going to get
paid for by Posit.
So you just get
an awesome mentee
to work with you for a year.
So if you're an open
source developer anywhere,
please reach out.
And the next question,
how have the program graduates
been doing long term?
How're things?
Yeah, they're all
over the place.
They're doing everything
from data science jobs,
but the kind of
cool thing about it
is people like Davon
is working with us.
We've got other
young people that
are working in data
science jobs that, one
has converted to python,
which is great, but, you know.
I won't say that too loudly.
But then there's
also some people
that just took the
training and then went
in a different direction
in what they cared about.
I think one of the cool
things about the program
is we're catching young people
at a really formative time
of their life.
So it's 17 to 23 or so.
And I'm sure you all
remember you didn't exactly
know what you wanted
to do when you were 17.
And so data science
could be cool for a while
and they learn
some stuff from us
and then they maybe go apply it
so the skills they
learn somewhere else.
And so we have some people that
end up in data science careers,
some people that
go back to school,
end up like doing
something totally
different but kind
of leveraging the training.
But we keep in touch
with all of them.
And so I'm always
texting with people
that have graduated
from the program
and it's cool to see that
community build over time.
So what are some
of the challenges
you faced in terms of both
kind of like buy in and just
like raising awareness
of the program?
Yeah so I think that
I tried to highlight
a couple of the key issues,
but like there's, there's
been a whole
collection of issues
in doing this, everything
from HR problems
to legal problems to
bureaucratic problems
to building data science
program problems.
And I think the core
message, though,
is that the thing
that helps most
is to think about the
target at the end.
So our goal is to help young
people get opportunities.
Sometimes
that's by building a
data science program,
but sometimes it's by Ashley and
I going to a million HR meetings
to try to create a new job code.
And so I think thinking about
that target, like what you're
trying to create at the end,
gives you a lot of leeway
to do all the things
you need to do
and then being flexible
about learning new things.
I think that's been the hard
thing for me, definitely.
I didn't know the
first thing about,
you know, I'm a biostatistician.
What do I know
about any of that?
But I'm learning over time.
And I feel like having smart
people I work with helps.
What about plans as you
transition to The Hutch?
Yeah so we're
getting ready to be
able to run the
program in Seattle.
So I'm excited about that.
And then it's
running in New York.
We have a couple
of other ambitions
about starting in a
couple of other cities
I can't announce quite yet, but
that we're going to start soon.
And so really now we're
at the stage where we're
excited about scaling it out.
And so it's been running in
Baltimore for a few years.
It's successful in
Baltimore, and I
think it's the kind
of program that
can very easily run in a
number of cities around the US
that I highlighted.
And so we're really
in this phase
of trying to get connected
to the right people who
are excited about
running those programs, so.
Awesome.
Thanks, Jeff.
Really and that was like
just amazing, uplifting keynote.
So thank you so much.
Appreciate it.